My name is A-Trak, I'm a DJ, producer,
record label owner.
The sort of, like, science of DJing,
if you try to boil it
down too much to a simple
description of beatmatching, for example,
definitely like an intangible to it.
On a very simple level,
beatmatching is what you
call matching the tempo of
one song to the next song
that's playing so that you
have a continuous beat.
And just going back to
the basic idea that DJs
keep people dancing.
You're able to keep the
tempo steady as you go from
song to song.
It's actually a pretty easy
technique, but DJing itself
is not that easy and I think
the real role of the DJ is
selection, it's picking
songs and having a sense of
what to play and when.
And that's the part that's
harder to break down or explain.
What really differentiates a good DJ
from a not so good DJ is
selection and taste and sense of timing
and also knowing how to
adapt to different crowds.
That's probably the biggest
thing that DJs have to learn
is to understand not only
what to play and when
but in which setting.
You can't play the same set everywhere.
Electronic music's been
around since the late '70s,
early '80s.
So electronic music isn't
new but EDM is this newer,
bigger, more polished manifestation of it.
And when it really broke in
America, at the beginning of
this decade, it's also
when certain songs were
really bona fide pop songs,
and were playing on the radio.
New audiences embraced
these big records that had a
universal appeal, and by
the same token embraced
the producers and DJs who
were behind those records.
More and more of these
festivals started popping up.
I think that confused a lot of people.
Just seeing a DJ essentially play songs
that were already made,
on the stage where
they'd be used to seeing
the Red Hot Chili Peppers or something.
People were questioning whether
DJs were really just pressing
play and that became a bit of a buzzword,
"pressing play" or "button pusher."
The range of different
styles that started existing
got almost too big to just
categorize as one thing.
So, do some DJs just go
up and press play and
phone in the same set at a lot of events?
Yeah.
Does that mean that all DJs do that, no.
A lot of DJs have true
craftsmanship and art
to what they do.
Usually the argument that
most people will give
and that I was just giving
also is that DJs don't
really play the same
set everywhere and we're
mixing live and all this stuff.
But in some cases when the
show is so big, that you
get into a place where there
actually is literally pyro
and effects that need to
be timed and this and that,
then you'll have a DJ who plans their set.
But even that to me, can
be compared to theater.
When you go watch theater,
it's pre-planned but it's
great entertainment.
In the case of a DJ, the
DJ is doing a sort of
mise-en-scène, of songs
that they know the crowd
will enjoy hearing.
And songs that they are
sometimes connected to or
that they made.
And translating that into
a show that will work
in front of 60,000 people.
There's an art to that too.
The control of energy is kind of magical
and undeniable.
And that's a big part of the art too.
So between that and
the sort of sonic wizardry
that happens with the knobs on here,
it definitely isn't
something to be diminished.